I've had a number of viewers asked me
about my time teaching in prison which
actually was my first full-time teaching
job and went on for six years at Indiana
State Prison so I've decided I'm going
to start shooting some some videos about
that I haven't really talked much about
that on video just in some of my classes
with some of my students from time to
time mine on Prison students and I've
done a few presentations here and there
about it yeah conferences but for the
most part I haven't actually sat down
and just focused on what the experience
of teaching in prison was like and I'm
not going to try to hit everything in
this single video so I think I'll do
maybe a set of these talking about
different aspects and this one I'm just
going to tell you about what it was like
when I first started out yeah and so a
little bit of backtracking is necessary
I finished up with my my graduate work
in 2002 down at Southern Illinois
University and by then I was kind of
burnt out on being in school and I
wanted to get out of Carbondale and I
moved to Northwestern Indiana and just
started looking for work up there
applying in when I had that at that time
I thought was a two mile radius
actually I sent out things a little bit
further because I was estimating how
long it would actually take to drive to
places wrong and one of the places that
I applied to it was Ball State
University and I didn't know at the time
but Indiana back in the early 2000s was
actually one of the nation's leader in
prison education you hear a lot about
you know other prison initiatives and
about people teaching here and there but
at that time Indiana was the state that
probably had the most programs for its
inmates and it wasn't very you know it
wasn't super selective it was trying to
get as many people into degree programs
as possible and the idea was it was
going to cover sitov ism and it really
did have some influence
sitov ism it's unfortunate that they
don't have the the programs in place the
way that they used to there were a lot
of decisions that got made that cut
those or you know shrunk them quite a
bit anyway
Ball State at that time he had about a
hundred and thirty professors full-time
professors who worked for extended
education in the prison systems so they
were all across the state of Indiana and
I got a call from the chair of the
philosophy and religious studies
department saying hey we've got a job we
need somebody to replace the person who
just left up at Indiana State Prison
which is Michigan City which was about
an hour from where I was living at the
time and a long ways from Ball State so
Ball State was having a difficult time
getting people to drive all the way up
there that usually have to stay
overnight and then they would teach you
know one or two full days and then drive
back down to Ball State so it was
actually a good situation for me that
particular prison any of the other
prisons would have been at least two
hours you know two and a half hours for
me to drive and she you know the chair
said are you interested in doing this
you'd have to teach this wide array of
classes but we looked at your your your
CV and we looked at your cover letter
then you seem like you'd be well
equipped for this do you have any
problem with teaching in an
institutional setting and I said well
you know I'm ex-military and I've lived
in a lot of fairly you know unsavory or
rough places so no I wouldn't really
bother me too much so she said okay well
sign you up and it was you know decent
salary to start with so I took it on I'm
going to sort of fast forward a little
bit the next thing that I had to do was
to go to orientation and I think you
know we had an orientation at Ball State
University so I did drive my phone out
that was like two and a half hours from
from where
I was living but then we have an
orientation at Indiana State Prison that
was led by this this guy who'd been
there for a long time as name's Gus and
so I get there and I'm always you know
arriving at places early because I you
know I want to find out what's going on
and make sure that I'm there on time so
I was there maybe about 20 minutes early
and there were quite a few other
professors there for the orientation
this was a yearly thing that we had to
to do I would say there are probably
about 25 to maybe 30 different
professors there and so these were all
the people who are going to be teaching
at that prison that year and you had to
go through a lot of Hoops you had to get
background check you had to get
fingerprinted you had to you know apply
for four different things you had to go
and get a badge that would allow you to
get in and out of the prisons and some
of that was being handled in the
orientation some that we did we did
beforehand the orientation was primarily
to sort of touch base with us tell us
about any new policy changes and then
sort of assimilate those of us who
hadn't been in the prison before and we
showed up and you you know you'd go
inside we met in this this locker room
and I'll tell you a little bit about the
structure of the prison in more detail a
little bit later so and then we went
through the first you know sort of
security checkpoint area where you get
your frisk you got you got to take all
the things out of your pockets sometimes
take your belt off definitely take your
shoes off all that sort of stuff
and then you have to go through a Sally
point and you have to go through the
captains office and then you go through
these sets of cages that open and close
and then we went to the chapel and
that's where we have the orientation one
of the things that Gus said that that he
begins with every time is there's only
two good things in prison that you can
count on one is religion and the other
is education everything else that these
guys experience is at best mediocre and
can get much much much much worse so
this is something the education is
something that many of these these men
in the prison really look forward to and
threw themselves into I have a little
bit of a digression here I want to tell
you about something else as well I
showed up and I was dressed in suit and
tie and I generally taught while I was
working in the prison if I wasn't in a
suit and tie and at least a jacket and
tie because for me there well there were
several reasons for this I I generally
dress up when I'm in the classroom
anyway even today you know 10 years
later and I do it in part because I want
to convey that what we're engaged in is
a serious academic pursuit that we're
not just screwing around or something
like that
and I think it's also in part a reaction
against the kind of let's dress
everything down you know a dress
everybody by first name kind of stuff
that that the baby boomer generation of
professors kind of brought in and turned
into a virtue I didn't like that when I
was a student I thought there needs to
actually be some legitimate distance
between student and professor that the
professor should be not necessarily like
you know somebody who's who's up on some
lofty plateau and you can't possibly
reach them but they're supposed to be
you know knowledgeable professional
provide you with an ideal that you can
then climb to and they're supposed to
help you out in that way but but they
have to be up there not just bringing
everything down and making everything
totally easy and and formal and I
actually took a lot of flack from my
colleagues for years for for dressing up
you know they didn't like the fact that
even more high I think in part because
that made them feel like they were
dressed up enough and a part they had
that ideology okay we're here to like
you know to be these moles within the
system and we're gonna we're gonna
liberate people's minds and all that I
didn't buy into that at all I'm not you
know I'm not a sort of get a
law-and-order conservative
to that but I don't buy any of the
liberal you know all these poor
prisoners there they're just totally
oppressed were there to help them you
know free their minds from the system I
don't buy any of that stuff either
and actually the prisoners hated that
sort of thing too they found that very
patronizing very demeaning and very
alienating ironically because these
people are the ones who are always
talking about alienation right Hey long
digression there's a connection between
what you wear and what you project I
don't want to project to these guys that
you know these were real college classes
yeah you know and some people kind of
dumb their classes down but that happens
on campus too Mike taught my classes is
if these were you know the same class
that I was teaching here as would be
taught any anywhere else and I extended
that to how I conducted myself in the
classroom well I have wore all those
sorts of things there's a story that
I've told in other cases too that kind
of represents the other extreme there
was one professor before I came on the
scene who would always wear like golf
shirts and you know casual wear in
coming into the prison and then one day
he was actually wearing a suit and tie
and he wasn't I don't think he was from
Ball State he was from some other place
and his students he asked him why are
you so dressed up you know coming to our
class and he said well after this I'm
leaving and then I'm going to teach my
real students and that really stuck with
them this impression that they were not
the the real students that they you know
what they were doing there was kind of
Mickey Mouse and making things easy to
sort of make work kind of stuff and that
you know that's destructive to any sort
of education so anyway back to that to
the orientation there there's long
orientation and then we were clear to
teach so I should tell you a little bit
about Indiana State Prison before I tell
you about what it was like to teach
there just some kind of general stuff
Indiana State Prison if you've seen
lockup extended-stay you've probably
seen some episode of shot at Indiana
Prison and it's a very old place it's
one of the oldest prisons in Indiana and
it's been rebuilt in a lot of ways you
know here and there but the foundations
are you know over 150 years old and some
of its in good shape some of its not not
in such good shape you know it's it's
like Gus said when we came in you know
think of the Shawshank Redemption
rather than odds odds is this really
nice high tech fairly clean place
Shawshank Redemption just bricks and
barbed wire everywhere that's the way
the Indiana State Prison is in old bars
that have been painted like hundreds of
times you know so much that they're
there there's just a thickness of paint
on almost lacquered on for two years now
Indiana State Prison was also a
maximum-security prison and it was a
little bit unusual in that it's not just
a maximum-security prison it's also the
prison in Indiana where death row is
housed we didn't have any contact with
death row as a matter of fact the other
prisoners generally don't either but it
was there and that's where they held the
execution so every once in a while there
would be an execution and everything
that'd be totally locked down and we
wouldn't have we wouldn't have class and
it would change the dynamic of the class
someone and I could talk about that in
some other video you know how they well
the prisoners felt about this at least
how they communicated that to me what we
talked about those sorts of things
so a maximum-security prison it's
designed to keep people in and it's
designed to keep people not just in as
like one big box but it's designed to
like choke off all the different
possible ways of movement to try to keep
them from hurting each other or engaging
in other sorts of you know illegal or
subversive activities now you you can't
actually make any prison completely
secure and you can't actually keep any
of these guys short of putting them into
a Supermax which was
all different kind of animal you can't
really totally control people instead
the best you can do is kind of try to
minimize the the likely things that are
gonna happen that's that's what they did
at ISP but ISP actually had quite a bit
of freedom and a lot of the guys who are
up there were happier being at is be
than they would be at other prisons down
state because those there's a whole
whole conversation there that we could
have as well who are the guys who were
in the president who are the guys who
are in my classes well most of them were
there for very serious offenses
typically murder that was probably the
most common offense so I'm kidnapping
some people were there for for rape then
there was a you know two other kind of
classes of people actually three so one
class of people that were sort of
separate from the general population
were the child molesters and there were
some child molesters up at Indiana State
Prison
they tried to you know sort of keep to
themselves as much as they could because
it is dangerous to be to be one of those
in prison especially when you're in with
a bunch of murderers right um the other
thing we were there were some drug
offenses some like really high sentence
drug offenses that were in that prison
as well not you know the rest of these
were all violent offenses these were
nonviolent offenses sometimes they had
other things on their record like a
burglary or something like that but some
people were in there because they got
caught with an awful lot of drugs and
then there were some people who were in
there in part because they their
security level was raised they they got
it originally for kind of small things
but then they were aggressive
they escaped or you know things like
that and so they're there security level
got bumped up and they got sent to a
maximum-security prison that was kind of
rare I'll tell you about one case of one
guy though that I knew that was really
kind of sad he was a young guy really
smart guy who was in some of my classes
and then he got transferred to up to
another prison and while he was in jail
he wasn't actually even in prison
originally he was just in jail he had
done a misdemeanor and he fell in with
two older guys who convinced him that
they'd break out and they could actually
get away and do that so even though he
only had a short time left on his jail
sentence he was kind of young and dumb
and he he broke up with these guys of
course all of them got caught and now
breaking out of jail that's a felony
he'd go to prison for that so he got a
long sentence
compared to his jail sentence for
breaking out of jail and he was serving
part of that indiana state prison and
then he was in some of my classes and i
really enjoyed having him in my classes
because like i said he was a really
bright guy and he wanted to learn he
wanted to further his education before i
tell you about what it was like to teach
these guys i should tell you about the
the environment itself so there's two
main things i'll tell you about in this
video
one is just like what it was like to go
through and get into the education
building and that what the actual
classrooms were like so you can use this
by sort of point of comparison to
whatever your educational experience is
like so you get to indiana state prison
you park your cutter in a lot put your
cell phone in the car anything else that
you can't possibly bring in you you
leave in the car including any any money
over twenty bucks and then you you you
know pick up your dossier or whatever
you're keeping your stuff in and you
walk through the gate past the big walls
and these these big walls really were
big giant
massive walls that had concertina wire
on the top and you know you're walking
through you can see the different towers
that they have observers and also rifle
in them just in case something would
happen so you go in and it's this this
really big structure you go through the
through the front gate and then they
have a little area off to the side where
there's lockers you know and that's
mostly for people who are like visiting
about prisoner but some professors would
put things into the lockers and then you
would have to go through the the main
checkpoint so what the main checkpoint
they're these big buckets it's kind of
like going to the airport these days you
know for me making the transition to the
the TSA regulations and and metal
detectors and the x-ray machines and all
that sort of stuff that didn't really
bother me because I was used to doing
that on a daily basis teaching at the
prison what really bothered me about it
was waiting for all the all the Yahoo's
in line who didn't know how to do this
sort of thing and would hold up the line
you know they'd forget to take their
shoes off until the last minute so you
would have these buckets and you would
you would and you also have little
little smaller metal buckets that you
would put all your change and you know
take off my watch and anything else and
my ring you know I used to carry a
classroom all the time everything would
go into that as a matter of fact I quit
wearing a necklace because I would have
to take that off and that would be be
kind of a pain so instead I would do
that you have to take your shoes off
your shoes go into the box your jacket
of course comes off everything else that
that could possibly be checked goes goes
in there and you would also
put all of your books supplies all that
all that would have to go through a an
x-ray machine and so there'd be a guard
doing that you'd walk through a metal
detector and you might set it off if you
do you got to go back through again and
then after that there would be a guard
he would Pat you down and these were
fairly cursory for us they Pat they they
would check the the people who were
visiting the prisoners a lot more
thoroughly than us but I mean there were
some people who still got in trouble
during during this process from time to
time and there were some screw-ups you
know I knew a guy who several times he
was a smoker and he brought through a
lighter and nobody caught it and he'd be
in the education building he'd be like
Oh God got you know I've got contraband
and this is like big contraband but
usually it would go that way and then
you'd have to wait show your ID and they
would open up this massive door and you
would walk through the Sally point and
there is a an officer behind bulletproof
glass and two sets of doors then usually
he would you know look you over and
you'd hold your ID up and then he'd open
the next door after the first one was
closed everything involves like you know
before they opened in one door the other
door closes and then you would go under
the captain's office through through
this this other but but every once in a
while kind of at random they might
actually open up this other door and
then send you in to be searched more
thoroughly not quite a strip search
you'd have to strip down to your
underwear and then they'd ask you a lot
of questions and then you know you just
get put everything back together and go
go through but I guess they they
probably caught some some people that
way I never actually saw anyone get
caught but that's what they would do if
there's anything suspicious or sometimes
you know just at random hey when you go
through to the captain's office and
there'd be a lot of officers kind of
knowing
and laughter while I get to know all the
staff and that wasn't that was kind of
nice it was fairly friendly but then you
had to give the captain your driver's
license and they would hold that while
you were in there you still had your
prison ID and the reason why they had
that driver's license is they needed to
know who was in there like a riot broke
out of course there was some sort of
natural disaster they'd be able to
identify it this is this person here
then you would go into this this kind of
cage and depending on which direction
you were going and after the door would
close the other the other gate would
open and you would go out into the yard
and the yard is kind of like this it's
not one big you know giant yard it's a
whole whole complex of like passages and
yards and different places and it was a
pretty you know straight shot to the
education building go to the education
building there'd be a guard there with a
you know massive key for a massive lock
that would have to unlock that door and
then you would go up and then they'd
lock the door behind you the very you
know security conscious and I you know I
never had any problem with that myself
because again I understood the purpose
behind it I don't have that kind of
ideology of you know power is oppressive
or anything like that and I'm
ex-military so I'm used to being around
people who are you who are ready to use
deadly force if necessary but but
generally aren't going to be doing
anything like that so we go up the
stairs and that would be in the
education building it was one big like
circle with you know a couple of offices
here in a lot of classrooms and then
there was one central place where the
the clerk was and we'd get our sheets
and I'm not sure what these sheets were
called our couches that's what they were
we'd we get our count sheets each day
and it would you know list all the
prisoners and there
and we'd have to like count them off at
the beginning of class because part of
the thing that part of what they do in
the prison is they want to know where
everybody is at any given point in time
so you actually have to have somebody
you know physically saying that person
is actually here so you'd get your stuff
and and by you know by a few weeks in I
realized that in order to do these
prison sessions because they were very
long I needed something you know like I
first I bring in soda but the soda
didn't help because the the sugar kind
of coats your vocal cords and so I
started bringing I had a tea a plastic
tea cup that I used and I would heat up
water and bring in tea and then I you
know drink tea and I also used coughed
rums
Ricola get to my classroom and I'd start
setting up and then guys would start
coming in and one thing I should tell
you about this to the classes were all
supposed to be seminar style so that
means ideally two and a half hours once
a week and the reason that they had to
do things this way rather than you know
like the normal college thing where
you'd have like you know two times a
week or three times a week for a shorter
period it was a prison so education had
to fit into the prison schedule and
there were certain like courses of time
and you know it would vary from time to
time so like when I first started you
could be guaranteed that morning classes
would start on time and you might
actually get extra time lunch classes
we're really iffy and you probably
wouldn't get your full two-and-a-half
hours probably closer to two or an hour
and a half and then the evening classes
you would generally get about two hours
maybe two and a half hours if nothing
gets screwed up but there you know
things could come along and interfere
like you know maybe somebody screwed up
a count and then now everybody's got to
go back to their selves and you never
see you have to be ready to adjust to
that kind of stuff and that took a
little doing on my part at first the
other thing that that imposed was you
had to be able to talk with these guys
for two and a half hours straight no
break and we were we were discouraged
from allowing prisoners
to like leave the classroom for any any
reason because there's only one guard in
the building I've never really made a
big deal of that song professor who like
really crack down on them because you
know to Nayef hours a long time if you
need to pass room to hold it all right
and that's not conducive to people
learning so I should talking about the
classrooms now so the classrooms range
at first from not so bad to terrible and
you didn't want to get the terrible
classrooms yeah and that you know you
could like talk with the right person
and you're trying to make it you know
make sure that you'd actually get a
decent classroom some of these
classrooms were actually used for a GED
they have other things you know prior to
college and then some of them were used
just for college classrooms and some of
the classrooms could fit a lot of guys
some could only fit like you know 20 and
that was really packing them in close so
generally the classrooms would of course
have one door in you know and that was
it and then there'd be a chalkboard at
the very end and be like a desk and so I
put all my stuff on the desk and I'd
have the chalkboard to work with some
had a small chalkboards I've had a big
chalkboard
I mean if guys had to leave for some
reason they'd go out the back which was
good as it didn't disrupt things too
much some of the classrooms are huge and
actually one was one gigantic classroom
that was partitioned off which didn't
work very well at all and one thing that
you can say about almost all the
classrooms they were noisy really really
noisy part of the reason was you know it
was summer and there was no
air-conditioning so we had to have the
windows open and that meant that you
know all the sound from the outside was
coming in and sometimes I could hear the
other professors you know she had the
students from you know one of their
other classrooms and then once they
actually got an air-conditioner that
thing was so noisy that you'd have to
shout over
of course once it got cold though there
was the heater and he had a shout over
that so it was it was sometimes
difficult to make yourself understood
you had to learn how to project your
voice very well how to listen another
thing that that you could say about
these classrooms the chalkboards were
terrible they've been written on so many
times that a lot of the actual truck the
background on the chocolate was like
flaking off there were some chalkboards
that were so bad like when I was
teaching logic I would actually bring in
sidewalk chalk you know the big thick
stuff so I could write on it and it
would actually be legible for my
students and they were constantly
playing this trying to catch up using
the you know the budgetary resources
that they had to try to repair some of
the chalkboards but if you got the wrong
classroom you you've got a really crappy
chalkboard the other thing I should
mention too is chalk was rationed we
have very very limited supplies and so
one of the things you have to do is like
scrounge chalk and then I would go to
the clerk yeah you know at the beginning
of some classes that you got a piece of
chalk for me and it gave me one piece is
he gonna make this last so you learned
the economy the prison students
themselves they had to do all of their
writing for the most part by hand on
paper that they had and that paper they
were only given a limited supply but
they were given a limited supply of pens
everything was very scarce the other
thing was that they were they were
provided with textbooks but the
textbooks had to come from Ball State's
central extended education warehouse and
we were limited to what was available in
that warehouse we could request new
things every once in a while and every
once in a while you'd actually get
something new that could be useful the
guy managed to get Kofi's introduction
for logic for the logic class but for
the most part you were stuck with
whatever they had and they might not
have enough textbooks before I started
some other professors actually
counted having to use no textbooks just
put notes up for the students and
explain the material to them like you
know one of my friends who taught
philosophy there thought you know intro
to philosophy and he was just like
here's what Plato taught and if you were
able to get this dialogue this is what
you would see in that dialogue just
imagine that's sort of teaching it's
very very very old method of teaching to
do that sort of thing by the time that I
came in we had textbooks some of them
were okay some of them weren't so good I
find myself on myself having to make a
lot of handouts for my students to
arrange the material so that they could
understand it well yeah and you know
some of the classes I talk over and over
and over again so I could reuse those
handouts some of them I only taught a
few times so you know I actually still
have almost all of these handouts but
they're all in old formats gonna work
perfect rather than the word so let me
tell you about the the students that the
students were all over the man there
were there were guys who a lot of guys
have gotten their GEDs in the prison but
that didn't mean that they weren't very
smart there were some guys who really
were not you know suited for college but
I would say that was a very very small
percentage most of these guys were it
wasn't intelligence necessarily that was
was the issue it was two other things
one was just you know preparation for
college in a lack of what we call
cultural literacy and that could be a
big handicap you know and I tried to
sort of fill in those gaps as much as I
could with with some of these guys I
mean they tended to be pretty pretty
appreciative of that you know they
wanted most of these guys really wanted
to
they really saw education as something
vital for themselves part of their the
process of turning their lives around
the other thing was motivation some guys
were were less motivated some guys are
very motivated some you know clearly
we're all only in it because you would
get a time cut if you got your
associate's degree to get a year off
your sentence and you would get two
extra years off your sentence if you got
a BA so you know going for years of
college that you know kind of kills some
time and you get another three years off
your sentence as a result I saw a lot of
guys who I know started precisely to get
the time cuts who about halfway through
the process something changed something
clicked something you know realigned for
them and they started saying oh yeah
this is really good for me this is
something I want to continue I wish I
would have realized these last two years
I've been kind of screwing around not
measuring up to my potential and I've
got two years left that I can actually
you know really work hard and get as
much of this out of this as I can so a
lot of guys go through this or the
transformation which I think there's
something really good for them not just
in terms of education but in terms of
moral Reformation
so anyway very wide range of abilities
one of the things I really liked about
Indiana State Prison I'll talk more
about this some some other video so I'll
just touch on it here was that there was
what I would call a culture of education
not just in the education department but
in the cellblocks there were a lot of
guys Ballston had been there for 20 or
so there were a lot of guys would go on
through the program a lot of older guys
would kind of guide the younger guys and
say this is something good for you and
you know quit screwing around and don't
mess with those professors you know show
them respect pay attention and so there
was a real value on education there's a
kind of continuity there that really
supported our work and
our role in interacting with these guys
and these guys many of them work very
hard after their studies with very
little to use you know in very tough
circumstances I know a lot of people you
know express views that why are we
giving these guys a free education in
prison
people who say that sort of stuff
generally haven't had much contact with
prison education and seeing how many
hoops these guys have to jump through
and how hard they they actually have to
work at least in the in the places that
I've seen what else to talk about oh
yeah that's that's sort of a good place
to leave love I wanted to end by talking
about something that I particularly
liked about about teaching for Ball
State in any M State Prison and that
culture of education is one thing when
you feel yourself part of a larger
project something that's really
meaningful something that is actually
making things better even if there's a
lot of setbacks there's a lot of lot a
little you know inconveniences and you
know indignities that you have to put up
with that brings the kind of focus to
your life and you know that that's part
of what made the experience of teaching
in prison meaningful for me the other
thing that I really liked and I guess
you know in part this is kind of
self-centered but it also was a benefit
to my students I get an opportunity to
teach over 20 different classes while I
was there cuz I had to teach philosophy
and religious studies classes and we
only have minors but I think I taught
about seven seven or eight different
religious studies classes I know I
taught at least 12 or 13 different
philosophy classes because we had to
cover the entire curriculum there was me
and one other guy who was who is
part-time at that prison
then mostly at another prison so I'm
teaching a four to five classes
sometimes six classes per semester at
that prison and there were a lot of guys
who wanted to take these these class and
some of them were staple classes like
intro to philosophy how to teach and
then religion in American culture and
world religions those are like staple
classes you know they satisfy the core
requirement but all the rest of them
satisfied you know electives or minor
requirements and so I have that like a
core of guys who would just keep on
taking classes and keep on taking
classes and that allowed me to get to
teach stuff that if I'd been in another
you know four-year on-campus institution
I would have been sort of pigeonhole
that but like the guy who just teaches
ethics and modern philosophy or I'm the
guy who teaches you know critical
thinking and intro and Ancients and I
wouldn't have gotten to teach all of
this stuff let alone to teach in two
different disciplines it made me do a
lot of work because I had to research
because you know I'm very conscientious
I had to research constantly to be able
to provide my students with the best
education possible and the best
materials that they could learn from and
it made me really grow as a professor
myself there were there are other ways
that it made me grow to you know I'm
gonna put up with with guys who are kind
of rough around the edges who knocked
off a lot of my on rough edges but I
really like the fact that I got to teach
so many different classes and that there
were guys who are interested in this
stuff
there was only one class that I offered
that I was I was sad that it didn't make
I wanted to teach a class on Allister
McIntyre's after virtue and they were
all sorts of screw-ups with the
registration that time around and we
didn't get it we had four students we
needed five students to make that class
of that class too
offered but there were other classes
that I got to keep today I probably
would have never gotten to teach
anywhere else because there have been
somebody else specialising in that like
American philosophy for example you know
I got to teach a class on that so the
minute I got to design a class and I got
to research a class and I got to have
students we interacted with them I got
to see what works and what doesn't work
so next time around if I've ever offered
the opportunity to do something like
that I know what I would do so it was a
really good experience for me a little
overall so this is already pretty long
that's where I'm gonna leave off I can
do more videos about the experience of
teaching in prison about other aspects
of it but that's where all we've offered